Fuck, Stream scheint online zu sein, huge.
Moin, weiter gehts.
China-Chinesen Zeug flaschen und hast du die Steckdosen geschafft?
Ne, die machen wir heute.
Komm, ich muss mir gleich noch was zu trinken holen, weil da wird der Hals immer so trocken,
wenn man jetzt hier 2-3 Stunden schwätzt.
Zumindest heute ist wieder, heute ist 2.
Teil Bass-Law-Stream, ich bin auch wieder hier am Start, Zack, Hunt-Reveal, ich bin wieder
am Start.
Ich zeig euch, ach ich muss euch noch was anderes zeigen, schaut mal her, guck mal,
also ich hoffe nicht.
Muss ich mir was auf GitHub zeigen, guck mal, also für alle die das letzte Mal nicht dabei
waren, das was wir das letzte Mal versucht haben ist folgendes, das letzte Mal hab ich
diese Dinger hier, Zack, oh, lag AF, w-wait, was ist das, warum lagts, Anzeige ist raus,
ach ich, ich weiß warum es laggt, weil ich dumm bin, weil ich den Browser doppelt aufhab,
dabei muss ich den hier groß machen, so, jetzt laggt hier auch nix mehr, Laggermans,
ok, also für alle die das letzte Mal nicht dabei waren, zeig ich das jetzt noch mal kurz
im Stream, also das letzte Mal haben wir versucht diese Dinger hier zu flaschen, das da, das
sind, ähm, Thermostate, China-Chinesen Thermostate, wo hab ich denn mein, ich mach das kurz mal
auf, weiß nicht, wo hab ich, ja hier ist die Batterie, ich hoffe das ist eins von denen
was angeht, also normalerweise sieht das folgendermaßen aus, ich guck mal ob das noch eines der geprickten
Geräte ist, jetzt mal kurz gucken, na, so, wenn es einer der geprickten Geräte ist,
dann leg ich jetzt die Batterie ein und es funktioniert nix, äh, warum musste das, ah,
ne, ne, ne, ah, boah, ah die Batterie hält nicht richtig, ok, aber normalerweise sieht
es dann so aus, Zack jetzt muss ich mal zumachen, also normalerweise sieht es dann so aus, das
ist jetzt, das ist jetzt Stock-Firmware, so, und das letzte Mal haben wir versucht die
zu flaschen mit Custom-Firmware, das hat nämlich den riesen Vorteil, es braucht viel, viel,
viel weniger Batterie und die Funktion ist genau die gleiche, so, das haben wir das letzte
Mal probiert und das Problem ist jetzt, was wir das letzte Mal hatten damit, so, das Problem
was wir das letzte Mal hatten damit ist, wir haben die Geräte kaputt gemacht, weil, zeig
ich jetzt mal, GitHub, genau, Handle-Leak, ja, so sieht es aus, so, und das letzte Mal
haben wir die Dinger kaputt gemacht, weil es einen Bug gibt, wobei ich weiß gar nicht
ob man das Bug, wirklich, wirklich Bug nennen kann, neue, neue Hardware-Revision gibt und
das sieht man in diesem Issue hier, so, es gibt nämlich seit 2000, 2021 07, nicht jetzt
2008, aber es ist 07, seit 2021 07 gibt es eine neue Revision und guck dir mal, was ich
da habe, China-Chinesen-Zeug 2021 07, so, Pech gehabt, wir konnten es zum Glück wieder
flashen auf Stock-Firmware und jetzt geht es wieder, zumindest das ist ein Bug, so, und
das haben noch mehr Leute festgestellt, dass das ein Bug ist, was heißt Bug, neue Hardware-Revision
halt, die haben den Display-Controller geändert, hier, irgendwas hiervon, also die haben jetzt
einen neuen Display-Controller, als im Vergleich zum letzten Mal drauf und wisst ihr was ich
jetzt gemacht habe, ich habe den Entwickler angeschrieben auf Twitter und habe ihn gefragt,
ihn hier, ich habe den Entwickler auf Twitter angeschrieben und gefragt, ob er zum Test
ein paar Geräte braucht und habe ihm die geschickt, das heißt, das habe ich gestern
losgeschickt, das heißt, vielleicht haben wir Glück und wir können die Dinger demnächst
flashen, weil sie das geschafft haben zu reverse-engineeren, aber die können ja auch
nicht zaubern, das heißt, das kann durchaus ein bisschen dauern, aber da soll mal einer
sagen, ich supporte keine Open Source-Dinger, ich habe ihm jetzt drei Stück geschickt, zwei
Stück original verpackt und den einen, den ich schon aufgeschraubt hatte, weil er musste
eh aufmachen, ja, und da sind wir das letzte Mal stehen geblieben, das heißt, damit können
wir heute nicht weitermachen, deswegen machen wir jetzt was anderes, gucken, ob es hier
mal irgendetwas Neues gibt. Deswegen machen wir heute was anderes, wie gesagt, also das
mit den Thermometern ist outdated, overrated, jebaited, da können wir heute nichts machen,
deswegen mache ich da jetzt auch mal die Batterie wieder raus, also wer schon immer im Wissen
von mir ist, 23,7 Grad und 57% Luftfeuchtigkeit und die China-Chinesen sind der Meinung, das
ist Happy Face, seid ihr auch der Meinung, das ist Happy Face oder sagt ihr, das ist
zu warm oder zu kalt, also ich würde sagen, das ist Happy Face, das ist schon in Ordnung,
man kann übrigens mit der, das beste Feature, das beste Feature, man kann den Smiley ändern
mit der Custom-Firmware, mit der Original-Firmware, zu warm, nee, warm ist das nicht, so zumindest
ich mache jetzt mal die Batterie wieder raus, ich weiß übrigens nicht, wie oft man das
hier auf und zu machen kann, wahrscheinlich ist es nach 5 mal auf und zu machen, ausgeleiert
und es ist kaputt, ok, aber es geht immer noch nicht richtig auf, das ist schon mal
gut, wenn es nicht richtig auf geht, dann heißt es nämlich, es sitzt immer noch fest,
das ist schon mal ok, so, gut, das machen wir jetzt mal weg, das schmeiße ich hier wieder
mal in so eine, nee, hier ist schon eins drin, das schmeiße ich mal wieder in so einen Packen
rein und dann gucken wir uns nämlich heute mal Steckdosen an, also das war jetzt ja nicht
so von Erfolg gekrönt das letzte Mal, also für alle, die nicht dabei waren, hat nicht
so gut funktioniert, weil neuer Display-Controller, was sagt ihr eigentlich zu den Poggers 3D
Print-Kicks, wenn die feinsten Strukturen sind es jetzt nicht so gerade, aber schon
nice oder, was predikten wir heute wieder, ich weiß nicht inwieweit es großartig war,
was zu predikten gibt, weil die Dinger werden wahrscheinlich funktionieren, müssen wir gucken,
was kosten die, meinst du die Steckdosen oder meinst du diese, meinst du die Dinger, du
meinst wahrscheinlich die Dinger, die kosten so gut wie nix, deswegen habe ich mir davon
ja auch bei Aliexpress einen 10er-Pack bestellt, guck mal, Aliexpress, zeig dir, ich zeig dir,
was das kostet, das ist wirklich, also eigentlich bei uns kostet die Batterie mehr, wenn du
so eine Knopfzelle holen willst, Xiaomi Thermostat, kann jetzt schreiben, so hier, sind diese Dinger
und da muss man gucken und du bezahlst, ich habe einen 10er-Pack bestellt, ich glaube,
das ist der 10er-Pack, für den 10er-Pack bezahlst du 2,90 Euro das Stück, das dauert nicht
lange, nee, das geht relativ schnell, guck mal, hier 10 Tage Lieferung, die China-Chinesen
sind ja nicht blöd, die haben Warenlage in Europa und die fliegen mittlerweile auch
viel, also du bezahlst 2,90 Euro das Stück, da kannst du dich wirklich nicht beschweren,
wie gesagt, für 2,90 Euro kriegst du im Supermarkt eine Packung Knopfzellen dafür, das ist eigentlich
fast hinterher geschmissen, wenn du überlegst, wenn du bei Amazon danach guckst, kostet es
glaube ich 15 Euro, guck mal, bei Amazon, okay, 9,69, aber trotzdem, das ist halt, das ist
halt schon ein bisschen, also der Preisunterschied ist schon heftig, so, deswegen sage ich ja,
China-Chinesen bestellen lohnt sich, 2,90 das Stück, gut, es kostet auch 3 Euro Versand,
sage ich mal, 3 Euro das Stück, warum sieht das Streamer nur die Emotes, weil du wahrscheinlich
nicht die richtigen Extensions installiert hast, also die normalen Emotes, Kampfrohr
solltest du auch sehen, also das hier zum Beispiel, das hier solltest du auch sehen,
wenn du allerdings die anderen Emotes nicht siehst, sowas hier zum Beispiel, dann fehlt
dir FFZ als, dann fehlt dir FFZ als Addon, da musst du, wenn du Chrome hast, das hier
installieren, das ist ein Chrome Addon und da kriegst du auf ganz vielen Channels tausende
Emotes dazu, nein Chatarino ist doof, Chatarino ist cool, aber Chatarino ist doof, weil es
unabhängig vom Stream ist, ich will den Chat neben dem Streamer haben im Browser, oder
bei der Twitch-TV, wobei ich FFZ lieber mag.
Die Simon Desue Stonk Strategie, Thermometer in China kaufen, 5x in DE verkaufen, die Simon
Desue Strategie ist Gewinnspiel machen und nie ausbezahlen, erinnert sich da noch irgendjemand
dran, alter dieser Typ, man, dass der immer noch in irgendeiner Art und Weise Relevanz
besitzt finde ich schon erschreckend das stream wird in mpv geschaut ja macht
macht was ihr wollt aber ich persönlich mag das nicht ich will ich will chat
und stream im browser haben 1000 euro in xbox für alle ja ich frage mich ja auch
also bei diesen ganzen challenges die ich auf youtube sehe ich will kein was
unterstellen aber ich frage mich zum beispiel bei channels wie sagen wir mal
bis der beast und so frage mich auch was von diesen challenges
sagt man mal ich will nicht sagen gefaked aber was von diesen challenges
haben wir mal sehr glückliche fügungen hat immer ja also es wird mich für ich
kann mir nicht vorstellen dass bei den ganzen sachen immer alles mit ganz mit
rechten dingen zu geht das hat auch einfach viel zu viel fake
potential das ist wie wenn ich sage also guck mal nur mal als beispiel wie easy
wie easy man bescheißen kann bei so gewinnspielen na ich könnte zum
beispiel sagen hey ich verlohse jetzt 10 max fps t-shirts habe ich nicht aber
kann ich sagen und da könnte ich sogar ein video machen wo ich irgendwie sagen
wir mal also ich gewinner ziehe ja mit random nummern oder so wer sagt denn
dass die nummern wirklich komplett random sind oder wer sagt denn dass ich
die gewinner wirklich random gepickt habe das ist das hat so viel fake
potential ich meine in der regel hast du da relativ wenig anreiz wenn du 10
t-shirts raushaust wenn du allerdings sagst hey ich sage nur dass ich 10
t-shirts verlohse aber ich verlohse ihnen t-shirt ja dann ist das was anderes
ja ein was klingt unanständig weil sie nicht was das sein soll so zumindest
heute machen wir was anderes das war ja das letzte mal nicht so von
erfolg gegründet wie gesagt also für alle die sich fragen was es ist was ich
euch gezeigt habe wie gesagt 2 euro 90 das stück ich empfehle es euch aber
explizit nicht zu kaufen weil ihr habt es ja gerade gesehen und ihr habt es
zumindest im letzten stream live mitbekommen jetzt auch die dinger kannst
du gerade nicht flaschen und die sind ohne custom firmen nicht so gut du hast
ungefähr ein halbes jahr batterie laufzeit und du brauchst china app
dafür und du brauchst die china app dafür dass es funktioniert mit custom
firmen kannst du es auslesen mit was du willst und die batterie hält über den
jahr weil irgendjemand bei den china chinesen hat sich gedacht es ist eine
sinnvolle idee dass so ein temperatursensor alle fünf sekunden die
werte verschicken muss ich habe es runtergestellt auf alle fünf minuten
weil ich mein ob jetzt ob ich jetzt die temperatur sagen wir mal aus meinem
temperatur luftfeuchtigkeit sagen wir mal aus meinem bad alle fünf sekunden
brauche ich würde ich mal sagen etwas fragwürdig
der chat erklärt erklärt die welt wieder ok habe ich schon nie was von gehört
ups was das gefahrt windows lull ks freak hat mal ein gewinnspiel war immer
gesagt demnächst das wundert mich nicht ks freak ist auch so ein spezialist
hat für einen plan von einer guten schreiblicht lampe ich ich zeig dir
eine richtig poggers lampe aber mit dem unterschied das ist keine wirklich
gute schreiblicht aber ich zeig dir mal eine selbstbaulampe die ich echt nice
finde sack wo habe ich es wo ist die lampe moment moment ich wusste jetzt
hol schau mal schau mich schau mich hier guck mal selbst selbst 3d gedruckte
lampe wie switch zu deinen bildschirme in dem fall gar nicht ich habe ich habe
hier ich habe die kamera auf und drück einfach fenster maximieren shortcut du
siehst ja guck mal maximieren du siehst es ist eigentlich ein browser lull also
hier 3d gedruckte 3d gedruckte lampe ist eigentlich wirklich schönes schönes
modell also für für günstig na natürlich ganz schön hier unten siehst
ja auch hier unten ist die ganze technik drin unten und so ein led-pedal soll ich
mal anschließen ich zeige es euch mal ich weiß nicht in welchem modus das angeht
brauche ich netzteil hier liegt eins die sache ist jetzt die was ist das für
netzteil das müssten 5 volt netzteil sein ist es
oh leggerino alter auf zu legen was ist denn hier los
ah nee das lag nicht das ist der fokus das ist der fokus von der vom iphone
guck mal der fokus vom iphone 5 volt netzteil excellent weil weil guck wenn
ich hier so dings ist überhaupt kein problem ist der fokus der irgendwie
ein bisschen rumspackt ok ich schließe mal kurz an also es muss auf jeden fall
5 volt netzteil sein weil es ist ein 5 volt microcontroller drin oder es ist
5 volt 16 mal 16 led matrix drin so ich schließe mal an pock like this so hier
zack so und da ist led drauf das kann man jetzt
steuern die sache ist nur die ich weiß die alpinen nicht aus dem kopf aber
das kann man steuern seck ich gehe mal kurz auf meinen zweiten bildschirm und
mach mal kurz die lampe aus da muss ich muss kurz mein heim automatisierung
stellzeug aufmachen licht aus und lampe ist das die lampe ja ok lampe so da kann
ich jetzt zum beispiel so dinger machen wie man sieht das in der kamera nicht
gut du kannst kannst die farben ändern du kannst auch so so abgedrehte dinger
machen wie sowas da und so das ist halt echt das ist halt echt nice das kannst
du dir das kannst du dir für 6 7 euro selber 3d drucken was ich halt echt cool
finde
wenn du ffz installiert hast gehst du in die settings von ffz und sagst
bettor tv emotes ein und animierte emotes ein und dann geht das easy
er kann sie alles alles mögliche einstellen ich kann es euch ich kann
es euch mal ich kann es euch mal zeigen wie das wie die wie das gui dazu aussieht
da muss ich aber erst mal raus bekommen was die lampe für eine ip hat sage ich
mal mal gleich aber was ich mein das willst du vielleicht sowas willst du
vielleicht nicht im schlafzimmer haben das gebe ich gebe ich euch schon recht
hatte mal integrationen wled das ist das richtige ich hoffe das ist das richtige
so so sieht dann das gui aus wo man das einschätzt man kann es home assistant
integrieren aber so sieht das denn so sieht das stand alone gui aus
guckt da kann man dann hier kann man dann hier umstellen umstellen oder oder
man sagt zum beispiel ne ne das will ich nicht wir machen wir wieder auf gelb und
da geht man auf effekte und sagt was zu silvester wirklich cool ist was zu
silvester wirklich cool ist fireworks 1d
besser silvester led effekt
hallo ist heute basteltag ja
ich bin am pc die ganze zeit
ja hast du zig hast du zig effekte was ich ganz cool finde ist einfach nur
feier das sieht an dem led streifen besser aus ich meine bei der lampe sieht
ein bisschen blöd aus na gut es sieht halt es sieht halt so ein
bisschen aus wie feuer was von was von unten drauf kommt man sieht ja man
sieht ja halbwegs also ich finde für selbst gebaut ist wirklich cool
es sieht ein bisschen blöd aus im in in der kamera muss ich sagen weil kurz
groß die einzelnen leds sehen in der kamera viel prägt dass die stechen
viel mehr raus in der kamera als als es wirklich in echt ist also hier sieht es
ja so aus in der kamera als ist als kannst du wirklich exakt die umrisse
einer jeden led ausmachen das ist gar nicht so wenn du dann echt draufguckst
naja gut das nur am rande weil es irgendjemand gerade von schreibtischlampen
hat ich glaube nicht dass es wirklich eine super empfehlenswerte schreibtischlampe
ist mit solchen effekten aber was ich bei der sache ganz cool finde du kannst
jetzt halt für 6 7 euro kannst du sowas selbst werden 3d drückgas ausbauen
was hast du für netzteil zeige ich dich mache es mal wieder
ich mache erst mal wieder licht an und das ding aus
so lampe aus was los an excellent was ich für netzteil habe ist folgendes ist
wobei ich habe mir gerade die lampe behalte ich war da können wir nachher die
geflächten steckdosen testen netzteil habe ich ein glaube ich viel zu
überdimensioniertes dafür 5 voll 10 ampere das ist viel zu viel du brauchst
5 volt netzteil ein ganz normales reicht 10 ampere ist schon krass übertrieben
dafür das brauchst du vielleicht wenn du alle wenn du wenn du 3 led streifen
komplett ins fenster rumaß willst dass die richtig hell sind aber das ist viel
viel zu viel wenn du wenn du das durch diese dünnen kabel macht wird es auch
ganz schön warm
ja big jongus genau seit wann hast du eigentlich so ein advanced ring light
woher weißt du dass es ein ring light ist habe ich schon die ganze zeit mein
allererster bastel stream war schon mit dem ring light was ist das ist mario
kartmusik die ist aber ziemlich ziemlich monka es oder
die hört gar nicht mehr auf
ja so schon besser wir können auch die andere anmachen
das ist ja so ein stream die lautstärke nicht mach mal kirby muss ich wenn eine
gute playlist hast schick her so jetzt habe ich euch das auch gezeigt mit der
lampe pock so es gab noch irgendeine frage wegen
technik wenn ich am rechner bin oder so
wo war denn das oder computer ja ich finde es jetzt nicht
wer hat denn da irgendwas gefragt
hast du das sensor things ab benutzt nee weiß nicht was das ist
keine ahnung was das ist genau das ist ein video zu der lampe wie man es genau
macht ja genau das hier ich habe gestern seit langen mal wieder
programmiert muss ein gui für ein projekt in pyson schreiben jetzt weiß
ich warum ich naja also native pyson gui ist ja auch hardcore pains champ das ist
immer noch dieses tk inter oder wie das heißt ne dieses naja old school gui
so ich weiß mal kurz das netzteil wieder in die eck
also was eine sensor things api ist weiß ich nicht keine ahnung sagt mir
jetzt nichts ich habe mein zeug in home assistant eingebunden meistens über
mqtt oder die offiziellen integrations die so gibt das war heute übrigens auch
mit den steckdosen so jetzt kommen wir zu eigentlichen sache heute muss man
kurz gucken ob der stream die richtige auflösung hat kann man das hier
halbwegs lesen ja smart plug tatsächlich wenn man so was hier lesen kann mit der
entfernung zu dieser kamera da weiß dass es 1080p ist dann ist alles gut
kennst du ndi 500 so ein stream converter wie obs ich kenne ich weiß dass es
einen ndi plugin gibt für obs da kann man zum beispiel in so eine komische
elgato app verwenden auf dem handy und darüber nach obs trümen wobei ich das
anders mache ich trümen das aus dem browser raus raus von vorm iphone
wird es ein weihnachtsbastel super mal gucken so also was wir heute machen ist
folgendes nachdem es ja das letzte mal alles nicht so sehr von erfolg gekrönt
war jetzt hier nachdem es ja das letzte mal alles nicht so sehr von erfolg
gekrönt war machen wir heute mal die steckdosen ich habe nämlich noch ein
paar china china china steckdosen von gosund ich mache jetzt nicht den
coronawitz mit gesund habe ich schon oft richtiger painstab witz den habe ich
schon zu oft gebracht aber ihr seht das wichtigste das wichtigste
schon mal hier unten made in china meint ihr das zeichen ist echt es gab
schon länger keinen hetzer stream mehr das ist richtig ich muss unbedingt mal
wieder ein machen wir müssen nämlich das serverprojekt mal fertig keck ws
service fertig bauen ke chin china export ach ja dann ist klar ich dachte
immer das steht für was anderes aber wenn es china export ist dann läuft
natürlich das ist sicherlich voll voll legit
mal davon abgesehen ich glaube in dem fall wirklich dass es echt ist weil ihr
seht das ist joint moment hier muss man kurz die maus wegschieben im bild das ist
bisschen im wesch das ist so so joint operations zwischen china chinesen und
polen blädiowsky also da kann ja nix schiefgehen
made in china verschickt aus polen alles klar da ist kein proje übrigens
letzt hat sich einer im stream beschwert ich würde mich zu sehr über china
chinesen lustig machen oder habe ich mich so im nachhinein gefragt der hat
nicht unrecht aber ich habe mich dann gefragt warum ist es ein problem wenn ich
mich über china chinesen lustig mache aber nicht wenn ich mich über mich
selbst lustig mache oder über ami holshäuser lustig mache oder sowas in
der richtung anscheinend ist das wohl wenn es chinesen sind ganz besonders
schlimm wenn man sich da drüber lustig macht oder microsoft indische hotline
mitarbeiter keine ahnung das hat doch jeder was so man sich drüber lustig
machen kann
ich sage ja kakona kakona holshäuser alter wenn ich die videos immer seh von
den amis wo sie sich dann mit der säge an die wand stellen sagen heute zeige ich
euch mal wie man ein altes haus giga 10 giga bit fit macht so stelle sich vor die
kamera ja hier also hier habe ich k7 kabel und ich habe eine säge und ich gehe
jetzt an die wand und mache ein loch in die wand
denke ich mir ok kakona alles klar das funktioniert bei uns nicht
da gibt es so viel da gibt es so viele videos auf youtube von das fällt also
wenn ich schon in den amis mit seiner säge da weiß ich gleich das video kann
ich skippen da bockst du die wand und schlägst durch oder gibt es lustig wo
ich noch jung war ja wo ich mich ab und zu mal zu zu etwas zu sehr rum reichen
hin habe reißen lassen keine ahnung da war ich 18 19 oder so und da habe ich
mich mal daheim übelst aufgeregt ja und da habe ich im schlafzimmer gegen den
kleiner schrank von meiner mutter geboxt und das war so einen press das war so
ein pressdings holtürenkleiderschrank ein loch drin das erzählte mir heute noch
das erzählte mir heute noch ja ja es gibt leute die machen kleiderschränge
kaputt ich habe mich ich habe mich keine ahnung über irgendwas ich weiß das ist
schon so lange her das weiß ich aber ich habe irgendwas auf gesagt so ein scheiß
also so kacke und habe dagegen auch das war jetzt ein bisschen fest
habt ihr den kleiderschranken auf einmal muss wegen killerspielen gewesen
sein ja und dann dagegen noch im schrank
das war übrigens noch vor call of duty überlegt war wisst ihr wann ich achte
wobei das könnte noch schon so wisst ihr wann ich 18 19 war ich bin 1984 geboren
zwar 2002 weiß gar nicht ob es da call of duty schon gab ich glaube den einser
gab es schon weil der einser basierte auf der quake 3 engine die muss das muss
es da schon gegeben haben
ok also heute china chinesen steckdosen die frage was das kostet kann ich nicht
so genau beantworten weil man muss bei aliexpress nicht schwachsinn man muss
bei amazon die habe ich von amazon deswegen glaube ich nämlich auch dass das ce
zeichen richtig ist man muss auf mehrere sachen achten wenn man so was bei
amazon kauft erstens muss es preislich natürlich attraktiv sein es hat keinen
sinn wenn ich 50 euro für eine vierer packe für eine vierer packung steckdosen
bei amazon bezahle da kann ich mir auch gleich cellys oder irgendwas halbwegs
gescheites kaufen also das muss so im bereich 30 maximal 35 euro für 10 stück
liegen dann kann man das machen ich würde sogar sagen er angebot 25 bis 30
dann ist dann ist richtig attraktiv die features müssen passen die steckdosen
habe ich bestellt weil das ist für mich das ist für mich somit die ultimative
china steckdose erst es war in dem bereich von 25 bis 30 euro ich habe die
im angebot gekauft und die haben einmal eine steckdose zweimal zweimal usb einen
schalter dass man sie auch schalten kann ohne dass man sie über web interface
machen muss und die können sogar noch messen
stromverbrauch die muss man aber ein bisschen kalibrieren mit das motor dass
es funktioniert so also die hat alles was man braucht du kannst den verbrauch
messen du hast schalter du hast eine steckdose und du hast zwei usb geräte und
noch besser es sind zwei relays drinnen ein relay für die steckdose und noch ein
relay mit spannungsverwandler für die usb für die usb stecker das heißt du
kannst unabhängig voneinander schalten was das zu einer ziemlich guten
steckdose macht das problem ist wenn du sowas bei amazon kaufst du weißt nicht
ob die sich flaschen lassen machst du mal ein kalibrieren wir
kalibrieren das heute wir testen das gleich wir machen das gleich das problem
ist wenn du die dinger bei amazon kaufst du weißt immer nicht ob die sich
flaschen lassen das beste was du machen kannst ist einmal in etwas motor
datenbank gucken ob du die steckdosen findest und gucken ob irgendjemand in den
amazon kommentaren geschrieben hat dass man die flaschen kann innerhalb der
letzten paar wochen aber selbst dann kann man sich nicht darauf verlassen und
mittlerweile haben die china chinesen auch abgecradet das gute ist warum diese
steckdosen sich flaschen lassen ist zwei sachen die basieren auf einem esp 82 66
das ist eine microcontroller die dinger sec
all das ist staubig also mal gucken ob ich hier noch irgendwie einen hier sowas
das da ist drin als controller also nicht so ein komplettes ding das silberne was
ihr hier seht das ist ein esp 266 und sowas sowas ist da auch drin das hat den
vorteil dafür gibt es halt so sachen wie das motor als custom firmen wir so das
ist das eine was wichtig ist also dass die dinger auf dem esp 86 oder auf dem
esp 32 basieren meist sogar in esp 25 ja das ist das gleiche aber ich glaube
in den anderen package oder so das ist ja das ist ja software gleiche so und das
nächste ist dass sie über die tuja cloud gehen diese zwei komponenten
zusammen in vor allem in der nicht so ganz aktuellen version diese zwei
komponenten zusammen sind relativ verbreitet und sorgen dafür dass man
sie flaschen kann allerdings muss man sagen die super chinesischen china
chinesen sind mittlerweile sehr trickreich was das angeht in der neuen
version kannst du sie nicht mehr flaschen und in den aller neuesten
version von solchen geräten ist da oftmals noch nicht mal mehr ein esp 82 66
drinnen und damit ist komplett flaschen mit das motor nicht möglich
nutzt ihr in der schule was diese steckdose und jetzt vielleicht noch mal
als erklärung warum sich das lohnt diese gerät zu flaschen wir gucken uns
jetzt auch gleich genau an mit webinterface und alles warum es das
lohnt im original brauchst du eine handy app die die steckdosen nicht etwa
direkt steuert sondern die steckdosen kommen ins wlan die steckdosen verbinden
sich zur china cloud und die app steuert eure steckdosen die eigentlich zwei
meter neben euch sind über china das ist das erste was man nicht will das
nächste ist oftmals ist es so wenn das internet nicht funktioniert da gehen die
steckdosen nicht im original und man kann sie schlecht auch noch integrieren
in andere lösungen also das optimale ist tatsächlich diese
dinger zu flaschen mittlerweile da die neueren geräte sich
oftmals nicht mehr flaschen lassen weil sie kein esp 82 66 mehr drin haben gibt
es mittlerweile ganz gute integrations für die tuja cloud aber ich sehe es
nicht ein geräte zu verwenden die über china kommunizieren müssen damit ich
meinen keine ahnung heizer im bad ein und ausschalten kann das muss einfach
nicht sein ich erinnere bloß mal daran die
leute die ich habe vergessen welcher anbieter das war die thermostate hatten
von diesem ein anbieter der wo vor zweieineinhalb jahren oder zwei jahren
aws probleme hatte wo die leute ihre thermostate ihre heizung nicht mal
steuern konnten weil aws daun war
wenn das internet nicht geht funktioniert die steckdose korrekt
korrekt je nachdem wie das gemacht ist es kann durchaus sein dass das
mittlerweile lokal übers fehlen steuern kann aber es ist auf jeden fall bei
diesen dinger immer die gefahr wenn das internet nicht geht dann gehen auch die
geräte die über die cloud gehen ich
ja hoffentlich machen sie das ja also sobald das alles offline geht ist ja doch
bei tuja geht das teilweise allerdings auch nur sehr um sehr umständlich da
musst du dir irgendeinen token generieren bei denen auf der seite im
developer portal und die legen ja auch ziemlich viel hürden in den weg dafür
also am besten ist wenn es geht flasht den scheiß mit das motor mit der
kastenfirme und dann habt ihr das beste aus allen welten zusammen auf welcher
plattform basiert dein smart home ich habe home assistant unten drunter für
alles mögliche das integrieren wir auch gleich daran
kannst du eine überwachungskamera empfehlen nicht wirklich ich habe ein
paar also 100 prozentig glücklich bin ich mit keiner wobei ich auch sagen muss
ich habe keine richtig teure ich habe jede menge billige wahrscheinlich hätte
ich mir meine ordentliche 300 euro kamera gekauft irgendwas gutes dann hätte
ich auch weniger probleme aber ja mir war es lieber dass ich das ganze also ich
habe ich habe eine kamera ich habe am hof da eine kamera ich habe im hof eine
kamera ich habe eine kamera im flur und im zimmer mit dem katzen klo ich weiß
ob ich sauber machen muss
also ich habe vier kameras eine reolink kamera eine weiß cam noch eine weiß
cam und die raspberry pi cam
nicht stimmt ja gar nicht und noch eine noch eine noch eine weiß cam die hatte
ich nämlich mal im pack bei amazon.com bestellt im keller für die halsung die
habe ich ganz verkehrt fünf stück
hast du das neue video vom bauer geguckt ja ansatzweise teilweise du meinst
dass jetzt das war nicht schlecht das können wir uns am sonntag angucken da
kann ich ein bisschen werbung für machen kann ich ihm sagen leute aus rufe
zeichen hetzner im chat wenn ihr euch einen 20 euro startgutschein für eure
versuche der hetzner klaut sichern wollte
exzellent
benutze ich selbst schon eine ganze weile kann ich nicht drüber meckern
so fangen wir mal an china chinesen steckdosen flaschen also was man dazu
machen muss ich überlege gerade wie man das jetzt am besten machen also was
was man dazu braucht ich habe das diesmal ein bisschen anders gemacht als
als das letzte mal das letzte mal habt ihr nämlich kaum was davon gesehen außer
wie es fertig flaschen war also was man braucht ist man braucht ein raspberry pi
und man braucht dieses software projekt hier
hoch was jetzt das da
dieses software präprämer das sieht man das ist auch relativ beliebt wenn ich
jetzt die irgendwie eingeblendet 3,2 tausend sterne ist ordentlich damit kann
man die sachen übers wlan flaschen ohne dass man die aufschrauben muss wenn das
nicht funktioniert weil man dazu neue firmware version hat aber man eine
steckdose erwischt hat wohl in sp 2866 drin ist dann kann man das aufschrauben
anlöten und flaschen haben wir auch schon mal in dem stream gemacht das ist da
wo ich mir so schwer getan habe das ding aufzukriegen
das ist aber dann doch etwas etwanzter
welches ist zu busse das ist man schau mit 3 wm ja mincode live schreibt ich
will mir ja mein smarter aus meinem zimmer machen aber gefühlt fällt alles
raus wegen privatsphäre will keine überwachungskamera sprachassistent für
regelung ja dann brauchst du geräte mit custom firmware oder sachen die du rein
offline betreiben kann so mache ich das auch also ich habe die wenigsten sachen
in der cloud fällt gar nicht gar nichts ein ob ich überhaupt was in der cloud
habe sehe ich auch nicht ein dass ich will meine heizung auch bedienen können
wenn die cloud down ist so also was wir jetzt brauchen ist folgendes wir brauchen
raspberry pi den haben wir schon hier am start ein raspberry pi mit frisch haben
das letzte mal im stream gemacht frisch geflashtem raspbian wobei in ein
raspberry pi os heißt ja direkt der weise über netzwerkabel angeschlossen
das ist ganz wichtig weil das wlan braucht er um die steckdose zu flaschen
und man kann sich nicht über das wlan verbinden und gleichzeitig steckdose
flaschen also brauchen wir es bei man braucht
dann das passende gerät was sich flaschen lässt und heute habe ich noch
was anderes dabei damit ihr mal ein bisschen zugucken könnt was da eigentlich
passiert ich habe hier meinen super small small access point das ist in
access point der kann nicht sonderlich viel 2,4 gigahertz only aber absolut
guckt mal hier miniature access point für 25 euro von mikrotik feature mäßig für
den preis eigentlich der beste access point der man sich vorstellen kann und
halt und halt wirklich mini furz klein schmoll schmoll access point matrix hd
danke für den sap danke auch leute alle die gesagt haben schon ich war jetzt so
am labern und hier und hier rumfuddeln ich habe die hälfte nicht mitbekommen
aus dem richtig pock ja small access point und ich habe mir gedacht zu small
access point brauchen wir ein small kabel das kann fast schon ein bisschen zu
groß sein dann machen wir mal den keks hier weg der keks steht gerade ein
bisschen im weg den müssen wir aber in die kammer den müssen wir in der
kamera behalten sonst ist sonst sackts exzellent ja ne da bleibt der muss hier
bleiben es geht nicht anders da muss da muss hier stehen bleiben
gibt es zu dem keks im model nee jeh nur danken für den sap so ist es wieder
im out vorschlag
so den war jetzt hier auch mal dran ach so ich brauche noch strom für den
access point fällt mir gerade auf small schmoll access point so also wir
brauchen einmal strom für den respiratory pie das habe ich hier da habe ich mir
auch vor einer weile mal so eine 50er box 50er box usb kabel bestellt bei
aliexpress 50er box usb kabel micro usb und usb c in einem hat sich wirklich
gelohnt seitdem zwar ich glaube ein meter oder was ist das eher eher ein meter
würde ich sagen ein meter kabel für unter 50 euro fünf stück also müsst
euch überlegen dass das ist teilweise echt verdammt billig bei den china
chinesen also ich habe irgendwie 80 cent pro kabel bezahlt du hast mit der usb
kabel qualitativ vollkommen in ordnung und inklusive micro micro usb und usb c
da kann sich wirklich beschweren wobei usb 3 würde ich da drüber nicht
unbedingt machen das geht wahrscheinlich nicht wie heißt der mini ap findet ihr
nicht bei mikrotik du musst gar nicht hier da da map light dann findest du den
da machen wir respiratory pie an wenn das alles funktioniert sollte der
eigentlich angehen macht er guckt da ist er respiratory pie an steckdose am
start platz oh seck ich habe ein problem seht ihr das moment moment
passt mal auf ich habe da so ein kleines problem
kein platz das wird okay das müssen wir müssen wir gerade mal ein bisschen
umbauen ich glaube das ist ich glaube das ist der das ist der switch der hier in
der ecke steht der staubig ist ob das hier ist der switch deswegen mache ich
das mal raus wenn es das licht ausgeht dann pech gehabt
okay so der switch ausgegangen das nehme ich hier rein und das dann geht das jetzt
jetzt ok das passt alles gut sehr schön aber wieder aus dem bild raus alter ist
er staubig wenn es interessiert was ich hier als als switch habe ich habe als
switch auch kann ich jetzt nicht richtig zeigen weil das unter dem stromkabel
hängt moment mal anders ob man mich das ein bisschen rüber über dingsen kann
ja das ist ein mikrotik cs man sieht es nicht richtig
css 610 8g das hat der hat 2 mal 10 gigabit und der rest 8 8 mal 1g
eigentlich optimaler tisch für optimaler switch und bastel basteltisch ja
oh nee pence champ musik
so ok ja wo sind wir stehen geblieben genau
raspberry pi ist dran steckdose haben wir hier small access point kommt jetzt auch
dran der braucht aber noch strom glaube ich hier habe ich ich glaube ich habe
hier noch was
gut small access point kriegt auch noch strom
ja
leuchtet also sollte man sieht sich richtig aber power leuchtet man
erkennt es nicht so wirklich aber ist zu zu hell so small access point am start
der wird jetzt angeschlossen gut so und ich mache es nämlich diesmal so wir
flaschen das ding über raspberry pi und danach melde ich an diesem access point
an der könne nämlich zusammen zugucken und und das ding konfigurieren
ok dann verbinde ich mich als erstes mal auf den access point ich glaube
1 2 3 7 hey oh shit oh shit was habe ich ihn da für den passwort fürs admin
interface vergeben
ist nicht atmen atmen ne ne ah schau mal glück gehabt noch mal glück
nochmal glück gehabt lol warum flascht man über den pie aus sicherheitsgründen weil
es das einfachste ist weil wir weil wir auf die er flaschen und das ist fix und
fertig einfach nur ausführen auf dem raspberry pie so das was ihr hier seht
ist die oberfläche von dem mini access point also vom small access point ist das
die oberfläche und ihr könnt euch vorstellen ihr habt wahrscheinlich noch
nie einen access point gesehen vor allem nicht so einen mini kleinen 25 euro
access point der so übertrieben viele options hat da läuft komplett
vollständiges mikrotik router os drauf das ist auf linux das ist quasi web
interface für für ihr linux unten drunter du kannst damit alles machen was
du dir so vorstellst ja von firewall bis dhcp server bis dns bis vpn du kannst
sogar vpn mit deinem access point machen für 25 euro also ich finde wer ein
bisschen router os basteln will ist das vielleicht schon fast der beste der
beste einstieg ja du hast eine router os genau du hast eine vollständige firewall
lösung also normaler paketfilter ohne irgendwie fancy fancy sachen aber ganz
ehrlich für 25 euro mini access point passt das gehen auch wie eins klar geht
alles habe ich jetzt damit noch nicht ausprobieren aber muss muss funktionen
warte mal bridge switch wie lang klar kannst du machen
kannst wie land anlegen oder oder faul an wie ich letztens wieder gehört habe
gut dhcp server leases das ist das was wir hauptsächlich gleich brauchen also
ich habe das ding folgendermaßen eingestellt networks wir haben 1 2 1 6 8
88 0 slash 24 das ist das wlan und dann hängt er bei mir einfach hier am
switch drinnen und geht über meinen normalen router ins internet raus also
dass das motor singen ohne markt jetzt kommen die leute wieder interpretieren
was in 88 rein das ist die fall mikrotik das ist die fall mikrotik kann
nichts dafür so guckt man sieht hier das sind das sind quasi dass das ist mein
meiner vm und das hier ist quasi der gateway was auch immer damit klaut will
ja cp kleint ja klar kommt kannst du ja ipsec vpn und alles und alles mögliche
mit mit machen
so ja alles da so was ich was ich eingestellt habe bei dem access point
ist eigentlich nicht viel ich habe das wlan eingeschaltet wie man hier sieht
ne ich habe das wlan ausgeschaltet wlan schalte ich gleich ein wlan ist
ausgeschaltet noch wlan ist konfiguriert kann ich einfach einschalten
dann geht's ich habe ein paar firewall regeln gemacht einfach nur um auf nummer
sicher zu gehen dass ich nicht aus Versehen irgendwie das ding irgendwie
discover oder sonst wie was ich habe ich habe simple firewall regel gemacht ich
habe gesagt verbindung auf das admin interface ist nur erlaubt aus dem
heimnetz und danach sollen jegliche pakete ins privaten netz getroppt werden
pakete ins internet sind ok
die habe ich nicht gemacht wir machen das ein firewall freischaltung auch noch
für unseren internen home assistant den wir beide mal einschalten sonst geht
er nachher nicht können wir gleich machen wir machen gleich wir machen gleich die
freischaltung dann vergesse ich nachher nicht und wundere mich nicht warum es
nicht funktioniert wir waren das gleich gleich wie heißt das ding map light von
mikrotik 25 euro mini exis point wie gesagt es ist kein sonderlich gut der
exis point in der heutigen zeit das hat nur 2,4 gigahertz und wahrscheinlich auch
nur eine antenne oder so also rein als exis point ist das jetzt bestimmt nicht
der knaller aber zum rumpasteln mit router os für so kleine bastel sachen
finde ich das ding optimal und wenn das ding seine ip spoof zu einer erlaubten
dann passiert nix warum passiert nix weil es ist nur accepted moment es wird
getroppt alles was sekunde destination address private netz ist also da kann der
absender ip so viel spuffen wie lustig ist es wird alles getroppt was ziel
privates netz ist
das war jetzt aber gleich eine firewall da war es aber gleich eine firewall
freischaltung weil sonst funktioniert es nachher nicht so firewall freischaltung
zu ich meine man muss sich mal überlegen das ist ein 25 euro exis point
ne mikrotik hat ja leider keinen aktuellen exis leider leider leider hat
mikrotik was wi-fi 6 und 6 e angeht bisschen geschissen wobei man sagen muss
die unify dinger sind da auch jetzt lange hatten die haben lange gebraucht
für so was dann auch krass ist wenn man sich überlegt das sind 25 euro ich
kann hier erstmal firewall freischaltung drauf machen ja so also wir brauchen eine
firewall freischaltung und zwar zu 192 168 2.133 das ist unser test home
assistant und wir das ding gleich registrieren drauf also mal eine firewall
freischaltung wir sagen forward das ist das gleiche wie bei ip tables falls
jemand mal von euch habt ihr schon mal ip tables verwendet unter linux ansonsten
sage ich ganz kurz was was diese drei verschiedene dinger sind also ip tables
ist so quasi oder eigentlich eigentlich eigentlich ist es ja nicht ip tables
sondern wie heißt das ding im köln packet filter ne ne ne packet filter ist
bsd ich weiß es gar nicht also wenn es ip tables ist das was man in der regel in
der regel verwendet warum hast du daheim ein 102 netz die frage ich eher warum
nicht also firewall technisch unter linux und auch bei vielen kommerziellen
so firewalls die eben auf linux aussetzen ist es oftmals so ich rede
jetzt nicht von den ganz fetten dingern aber gerade hier von wenn man sich
bei mikrotik anguckt was ja quasi in den linux ist mit webinterface dafür das
ist folgendermaßen ip tables kennt prinzipiell erstmal drei verschiedene
wege um pakete zu befördern nennen wir es mal so ja es gibt forward input
output input bedeutet das gerät selbst was auf das gerät selbst zugreifen will
kannst du mit der input regel steuern forward bedeutet was das gerät routet
sprich welche pakete das gerät weiterleitet und output bin ich mir
ehrlich gesagt nicht sicher ich glaube das ist für natt aber wichtig ist
forward input input muss man immer einstellen input das quasi ist jetzt
ja auch hier ich habe eingestellt input except input nur von meinem admin netz
das heißt das webinterface zum administrieren von diesem access point
kann ich nur aufmachen wenn ich von dem internetz komme
wenn wir gar nicht sicher was output ist ich glaube das ist für für natt
geschichten so also wir brauchen neue firewall regel was haben wir gesagt also
forward ist es in dem fall weil wir leiten ja weiter und wir wollen zu
destination address 122 168 2133 das heißt wir sagen destination address
122 168 2.13 ich habe schon wieder vergessen 133 133 so gut wunderbar mehr
muss man nicht machen man kann jetzt auch input output interface sagen man sagt
ok input interface ist wlan output interface ist dann in dem fall in das
netzwerk gerät wobei das in dem fall ziemlich wurscht ist es gibt nur einen
weg wunderbar das soll accepted werden
enabled habe ich gesagt except except und dann schieben wir das ganze mal hier
oben hin das heißt es ist jetzt alles erlaubt aus
dem wlan auf diese interne ip das ist vielleicht nicht so sinnvoll das will
man vielleicht nicht haben deswegen kann man auch sagen ok wir
schränken das ganze noch ein auf tcp und sagen destination port nur mqtt
mal gucken was mqtt voll 1883 so wir wollen das quasi nur auf diesem port
haben und jetzt ist nur erlaubt wohlgemerkt wir reden von 25 euro access
point jetzt ist nur erlaubt von wlan zu netzwerk
nur diese ziel ip die protokoll tcp destination port mqtt default
das ist also so brauchen wir das jetzt
zurück zu den gelungen bettel für den super klick zahll ja poggers ne ich habe
schon überlegt ob ich nicht noch eins raushauen aber als nächstes muss ich
das video mit her endpunkt bringen sonst sonst steigen mir die leute aufs dach
wobei ich mir noch nicht ganz sicher bin ob ich als nächstes das video mit der
endpunkt bringe oder als nächstes ein fast schon fertiges stellenanzeigen
review video
her endpunkt heißt übrigens niklas darf ich jetzt verraten er hat gesagt ich
darf sein namen verraten ehemalige azubi von mir also wer es nicht kennt ich habe
immer ein video gemacht wo ich mich über ein paar seine eskapaden lustig
gemacht habe und er hat sich nach dem video bei mir gemeldet hat gesagt hier
max ich bin her endpunkt habe ich ein paar testfragen gestellt es ist wirklich
und habe ich mit ihm was aufgenommen so wie es ihm dann ergangen ist
brauchst du noch super duper alles admin schnell klar klar schick her schick her
poggers ein nachnamen sage ich nicht ganz ganz ruhig schicken ich glaube wir
machen im discord auch so was ok also wir haben jetzt unseren access point am
start jetzt gehen wir mal in dhcp server leases so wenn wenn wir das ding
geflasht haben und dann diesem access point anmelden dann bekommen wir hier
eine lp zugewiesen und dann sehen wir das hier und dann können wir uns hier drauf
connecten also auf geht's würde ich sagen als nächstes müssen wir das
müssen wir die steckdose mit dem raspberry pi flaschen das heißt wir
verbinden uns jetzt erstmal auf den raspberry pi ich hoffe die lp stimmt
scheint zu stimmen ich habe einfach die letzten raspberry pi
genommen den ich in der history habe
das scheint ja auch zu sein wir machen noch wir machen noch mal
update nummer auf nummer sicher zu gehen so und jeder der flaschen will der
selbst seine steckdose flaschen muss jetzt aufpassen weil so funktioniert das
ist total einfach man geht auf github github tuja convert
lustigerweise ein projekt von der ct also heise quasi so man nimmt das projekt
also man nimmt sich diese uhr vom github projekt geht auf seinen raspberry pi
installiert sich erst mal eine runde shit shit weil wir brauchen jetzt shit um
das repo zu klonen und dann wenn er fertig ist
so geht klonen dann klonen wir das in den ordner und das war es mehr oder
weniger schon der rest geht mit einem assistent
jithub genau da hat er niklas echt was angerichtet dass ich heute noch shit
sage oder jit zu git so das nächste was man machen muss man sagt hier install
install prerequisites prerequisites da brauchen paar dinger da braucht den
mqtt server glaube und dinger keine ahnung einfach einfach ausführen und
machen das raspberry pi 4 aber das geht genauso
gut mit dem also das hier das ist ein raspberry pi 4 mit dem mit dem
fliercase aber das geht ganz genauso gut mit dem raspberry pi 3
nee ich glaube das ist in den ich gucke mal gleich wie viel ram das ding hat ich
gehe davon aus dass es in 4 gigabyte raspberry pi
und jetzt können wir nur hoffen dass ich die dinger auch ordentlich flaschen
lassen flasche reno wenn einmal kurz gucken
wie ja 4 gigabyte 4 gigabyte raspberry pi ja heute habe ich auf der arbeit einen
ticket bekommen achtung von unserem support achtung
swap space auf surfer xy voll achtung swap space habe ich mir gesagt was
warum was interessiert mich ob der server swap so oder hat da habe ich ihn
gefragt der der mir das ticket gegeben hat hat ja wie viel ram ist er noch
frei oder meint er 20 gigabyte was juckt mich ob das ding swappt wenn er
noch also erstens natürlich die frage warum swap der wenn er 20 gigabyte
freiheit aber wenn die wege des linux kernels sind unergründlich was das
swapping angeht manchmal aber wenn ein server 20 gigabyte freies ram hat da
muss man sich keine gedanken machen vor allem kein emergency ticket hohe hohe
wie heißt bei uns hohe priorität angeben
sauberig keck wait wir haben nicht die voll swappiness damit so ein mist
normalerweise gar nicht auflegt so gut fertig also sag next start start flash
so und jetzt muss man darauf achten was dieser assistent einem sagt please read
this carefully das machen wir jetzt nicht careful
yes wir wissen bescheid alles klar keiner übernimmt die garantie dafür alles
gut yes do you wish to terminate jaja mach yes
so exis point wird aufgemacht so und jetzt kommt gleich ein ganz wichtiger
hinweis man muss dass das funktioniert man muss ein weiteres gerät das hier ist
ganz wichtig sonst funktioniert es nicht das ding macht jetzt in exis point auf
der wie trust heißt damit das mit dem flaschen funktioniert ist man muss ein
weiteres gerät in dieses wlan packen auch wenn das nicht steht es steht es
mittlerweile gar nicht hier connect any other device also muss beispielsweise
sein smartphone oder den tablet oder sonst was in dieses wie trust wlan
hängen das mache ich jetzt mal hier off screen mit
dem ipad das kann ich euch nicht zeigen aber ihr geht einfach in bei
irgendeinem x beliebigen gerät in die wlan settings und joint eine wlan was
wie trust heißt nix no no gachi bus wie trust flash ihr connectet euch da dran
so und jetzt wird spannend jetzt kommt die geschichte mit der
steckdose put your iot device in auto konfig smart konfig pairing mode led
will blink fast ok das macht der automatisch das heißt das einzige was
wir jetzt machen müssen theoretisch ist die steckdose einstecken
klingt vertrauenswürdig wird das ist open source project du kannst gucken was
es macht so hier ich versuchte es mal ein bisschen bisschen hinzuziehen geht
nicht so wirklich gut aber also das einzige was wir jetzt wirklich machen
muss ist die steckdose einstecken und dann gucken dass es im pairing modus
blinkt schauen wir mal versuche ich das mal so zu zeigen pairing modus sollte im
pairing modus sein immer auf den raspberry pi und sagen
enta enta enta ist die verbindung zum pi abgekackt
aber weil habe ich etwas rausgezogen wie grad
ich habe tatsächlich mein kabel rausgezogen ja ich habe meine ich habe
mein das gar kein lvl das sind direkt attach kabel ja aber habe ich aus
für den rausgezogen lull zwar wir haben jetzt nicht gesehen wir haben sich
gesehen hat geflasht aber wir machen das ja noch dreimal ihr seht es guckt hier
er flasht er flasht das ding jetzt gerade er flasht das ding jetzt gerade
hier oder hat es geflasht ja funktioniert er flasht wir haben nichts
verpasst der flascht jetzt da ist nichts prickt der flascht jetzt da sieht man
auch nichts bei der steckdose also ihr müsst euch dann gar nicht wundern wenn
da irgendwie nix blinkt oder so das ist normal man sieht da nix
what the fuck ok also ready to flash third party firmware alles klar wir
wollen flascht das motor machen zwei are you sure das motor bin point of no
return yes der prickt nicht der chat wieder warum seid ihr so scharf drauf
dass ich 30 euro sachen kaputt machen wobei die hatte kein 30 euro das waren
vier stück für 30 euro so jetzt ist das ding geflasht und was jetzt passiert ist
folgendes das kann ich euch jetzt auf dem tablet zeigen
cancel jetzt gibt es den wlan die die steckdose aufmacht jetzt versuche ich
das mal zu zeigen seck moment bin dazu zu nubisch für ok alter ist richtig
pepega hier übers iphone übers ipad ok folgendes hier das passiert jetzt
erkennt erkennt man das so wenn man wenn man sich jetzt hier verbindet zu nah das
ihr nicht kennt man nicht gescheit und wenn ich muss ich muss es groß machen
zack lull ich muss das groß machen und sieht man ja gar nix so jetzt jetzt
jetzt sieht man es ganz genau also das das das bekommt man dann wenn man sich
versucht zu diesem exes guckt ihr seht hier oben das motor das das ding macht
ein exes point auf und damit man sich da jetzt connecten kann muss man folgendes
machen wir machen jetzt in unserem small exes point ipad leak omg wir machen jetzt
in unserem small exes point über hier irgendwo haben
warte in unserem small exes point machen wir jetzt das wlan an
und dann connecten wir uns zu diesem exes point und ich gehe mal hier dass ihr
das gleich seht auf leases dass ich bei dhcp was bekomme
so ich sehe gerade wie wir das jetzt gescheit machen
ich muss gerade mal aufmachen auf dem tablet
so ok also fullscreen ich darf jetzt so das password nicht liegen lull also
fullscreen man kann jetzt nicht so viel verkehrt machen
man kriegt jetzt dieses eingabe ding hier auf dem tablet so was man jetzt macht ist
man geht hier drauf sagt hey wir wollen exes point wir wollen dem exes point
join exes point ist in dem fall home 3 und das password sage ich euch jetzt nicht
weil monka monka leak so wenn man sich da jetzt vertippt ist ziemlich dumm weil
dann muss man das ding resetten und es sagt ich glaube ich habe mich vertippt
lull moment sag ich doch ok alles klar passt domain plan danach sagt ihr safe
danach sagt ihr safe
und es war es dann steht da es reconnected und während wenn das
reconnectet dann sollte es jetzt zum exes point reconnecten
oh guck mal da was haben wir denn da eine lies was könnte das wohl nur sein was
jeder dynamische ip bekommen hat das klingt ja ganz nach uns kommt das motor
oder auch nicht ach so ich habe gar keine route dahin moment wie komme ich
denn da jetzt dran da habe ich mir mit small mit dem small exes point noch gar
keine gedanken gemacht wie komme ich denn da jetzt hin
das an der exes point für eine ip also muss ich jetzt sagen moment und root
et 192 188 8.0 slash 24
was da jeder so mit slash 24 das kriegst du aus dem kopf jetzt nicht gebacken
op gut et muss geweder vormachen nee oh nee oder war das 355 muss man das so
machen
oh fuck ich weiß aus dem kopf nicht mehr ah scheint zu gehen doch 88 ping 122 168
88 154 nope
okay das ist jetzt dumm wie komme ich jetzt an die kässe dran das muss doch
jetzt eigentlich funktionieren
das ist feierwald problem ist das sollte eigentlich kein feierwald problem sein
weil ich alles erlaubt habe vor moment nein ich habe nicht alles erlaubt von
lokal das ist bestimmt ein feierwald problem also et wir wollen source source
address slash 24 in interface things out interface wireless alles erlauben
ich hoffe das stimmt was ich hier treibe back ja gut moment geht es überhaupt
richtig traceroute traceroute das geht falsch das geht falsch ich habe nicht
ich habe nicht richtig ich habe keine richtige route gesetzt ach du scheiße
wie geht das das war jetzt meine gut das war ich doch jetzt aus dem kopf nicht
wie setze ich eine route für das netzmensch chat ihr wisst das doch ihr
wisst das doch bestimmt aus dem kopf feier hier so ja ip root ads jetzt big
brain oho und jetzt traceroute das sieht besser aus
das geht immer noch nicht but why
also ist richtig aber der weg zurück fehlt das stimmt der weg ne ne der weg
zurück der weg zurück
eigentlich nicht das ist direkt angeschlossen das ist nicht der
respire da muss ich jetzt mal kurz überlegen die icmp ist nicht
deaktiviert wie kriege ich das alte wieder weg ja das hätte ich vielleicht
vorher mal ausprobieren sollen geht es irgendwie denn ja die feier wollen nicht
die steckt aus wir können mal gucken ob es prinzipiell funktioniert wir machen
wir machen einfach mal ein ping da drüber also server ip von dem ding ist
folgendes hier 1 2 1 6 8 das da es kann wirklich sein dass der rück der
rückweg ist so wir machen es mal ein ping von von der kiste aus dazu geben
wir mal hier terminal ich glaube das ist einfacher man kann auch ping über
penta face machen aber in ping 1 und 2 1 ich weiß gar nicht wie die wie man den
ping von mikrotik auf der kommando zeile bedient
heimhaut wait a minute warum der router selbst sollte aber nicht heimhauten
keck wait der router selbst sollte definitiv nicht heimhauten kaputt seh eine
feierwahl geschichte geht aber das richtige interface raus naja es sind zwei
sachen angeschlossen es muss schon aber trace trace root nähe keine ahnung wie
das hier funktioniert mikrotik kommando zeile kann ich nicht wirklich gut
last scene hat sich das ding ausgeschaltet sec und make static da
kriegt immer die gleiche ip ich ich ich starte das ich starte das mal neu ich
starte das ding mal neu die man mal steckt aus raus kann man jetzt ja
gefahrlos machen kein problem steck mal die steckdose wieder rein
expires after ok deshalb jetzt hat sich das definitiv was geholt
monka es warum warum kann der router selbst das ding nicht pingen habe ich
irgendwelche feierwahl geschichten monka es sich eingerichtet oder was ist hier
los also zumindest der router selbst sollte das doch pingen können
warum geht das nicht also ich gehe davon aus das ding ist ab
gar keine frage so es wird in feierwahl in der feierwahl geschichte sein also wir
haben vorwärts ist alles erlaubt
vorwärts ist alles erlaubt
die antwort von der steckdose muss in bau den router erlaubt sein stimmt wenn
ich den router pinge muss das erlaubt sein wobei ich habe
das liegt hier dran glaube ich das muss ich weiter runter machen
wartet mal wartet mal ich habe ich hab mich glaube ich selbst gebaited ich
glaube ich selbst gebaited weil ich habe es täglich related das müsste aber
eigentlich doch funktionieren das ist das ist die antwort darauf das müsste
eigentlich klappen haha ich habe mich selbst gebaited mit einer
bescheuerten regel hier jetzt kann der router zwar selbst nicht
pingen aber ich komme drauf
ja gut ob der router selbst pingen kann oder nicht ist mir vollkommen egal aber
ich komme drauf alles klar so ich habe ich habe mich selbst gebaited mit meiner
komischen regel hier die ich aber eigentlich
gar nicht bräuchte oder
bräuchte ich gar nicht weil ich tropf doch eh alles was nicht erlaubt ist
ok ich glaube ich glaube ich habe ich glaube ich habe es gecheckt warum das
nicht funktioniert der ping kommt an aber der ping kommt nicht zurück das
heißt ich muss das da oben drüber schieben und jetzt geht's das ist das
ist die antwort erlauben alles klar ok wunderbar ip am start sagt kann man es
darauf verbinden und wir haben unser tas motor am start wir können jetzt die
steckdose ab und ausschalten dass mich mal kurz hören ob es funktioniert es
funktioniert nichts wir können ich ich blende es euch ich blende es euch hier
oben mal ein in der hoffnung dass ich das hinkriege ohne das kabel irgendwie
wieder rausreißen so dass ihr das seht
seck müssen das so machen sieht jetzt zwar nicht schön aus aber zweckmäßig
also wenn alles funktioniert wenn alles funktioniert kann ich über das web
interface das ding an und ausschalten und dann geht hier auch die steckdose an
und aus template setzen genau dann geht auch die steckdose aus aktuell passiert
gar nichts aber wenn ich hier drauf drücke passiert auch nichts weil er
keine ahnung hat wie das interne relay mit diesem schalter zusammenhängt
deswegen muss ich mir tatsächlich genau was hat gesagt ein template dafür
raussuchen das macht mal folgendermaßen können
bei der wei auch gleich mal das motor upgraden dazu geben wir mal github das
motor das ist da wo die firme herkommt immer offiziell die github repo und was
passiert eigentlich wenn die dinger custom geflasht abfangen nichts du hast
ja hardware mäßig nichts geändert warum sollten die abfangen durch custom
firmen so der michael wo ist der michael 50 billionen jetzt halt jetzt ist hier
mal was richtig benannt also guck mal wir haben wir haben das motor 920 und es
gibt schon das motor 950 wir abkühlen jetzt das ist rausgekommen vor ein paar
monaten das machen wir jetzt upgrade so nicht nicht de brauchen wir nicht das motor bin
otr das motor wir nehmen das von der von der von der gescheiten seite hier also
das motor bin gz gg es download safe hoffentlich ist genug platz drauf dass ich
updaten kann wenn ich kann ich euch gleich mal auch zeigen wie man wie man
richtig das motor updated es gibt da nämlich so ein paar stolpersteine in
die man in die man fallen könnte schiebt es mal hier vor dass ich das wieder
findet also wenn man das motor upgraden will einfach den otr link einfügen das
würde ich tatsächlich mal ich würde selbst updaten weil in einem normalen
otw land kommen die kisten auch nicht ins internet so firmen upgrade upgrade
das motor bin gz so jetzt kann es zu einem problem führen dass das gerät
nicht genug speicher hat zum upgraden das sagte einem aber dann so upgrade start
upgrade so der upload jetzt und wenn er zu wenig speicher hat wird er meckern es
kann durchaus sein dass die dinger zu wenig speicher wenn die zu wenig speicher
haben da muss man einen trick machen dass das ok es hat funktioniert wenn die
nämlich zu wenig speicher haben dann muss man erst eine minimalfirma flaschen
und danach die richtige firma flaschen so jetzt haben wir das ding geupgraded
hier machen wir unseren access point hier auf den schieb ich auch ein bisschen vor
access point dhcp dhcp leases alles klar hat es nix getan ist auch wieder neu
gestartet man man bekommt relativ einfach mit ob
iot geräte neu gestartet sind wenn die lease time sich resettet für die dhcp
adresse weil ansonsten sieht man es nicht und manchmal sind die geräte auch im
keller so da sind wir neueste das motor version porgers easy update easy life so
und jetzt kommt das wichtigste was man machen muss damit das motor geräte
funktionieren man muss das motor geräten ein template setzen template ist ein das
ist falsch hat man genau also man kann das template entweder von hand
konfigurieren welche pins wohin gemapt sind das ist für ein arsch
man muss hier rein und dann geht man ins internet und sucht sich in einer
tasmotardatenbank raus was man denn für ein gerät hat und was man für ein
template braucht da gibt es beispielsweise die hier und da suchen wir
jetzt mal unsere steckdose raus ist search search gosund sp irgendwas
heißen die dinger gosund sp so wenn wir glück haben das könnten die sein sp 112
es gibt aber auch die also wir haben jetzt zur auswahl zwei verschiedene
versionen dass wir da so ein bisschen so ein bisschen pains jam die muss man jetzt
einfach ausprobieren was man auch noch gucken kann ist aber das das bringt
meistens nix man kann irgendwo gucken hat sich im chat gerade einer geschrieben
genau konfigure konfigure module wo ist wo ist das ja ob das hier schon drin
steht aber in der regel steht das hier nicht drinne
guck da steht in die gosund sp 1 also in der regel sind sind die templates für
die geräte nicht nicht mit dabei so deswegen geht man sich auf konfiguriert
also sucht sich hier das passende template raus jetzt ist die frage was
wir nehmen gosund v 34 oder gosund
ja wir haben zur auswahl die versionen v 34 und die versionen dings also was ist
in der unterschied dazwischen
it is possible that your device will enter a boot loop das ist schlecht das
ist das ist schlecht boot loop doch es kann was passieren boot loop ist
schlecht das device now comes with wifi module in combat o die neuen old version
ah die neue version geht mit das motor gar nicht also die wollten uns die
wollten uns eigentlich nur darauf hinweisen dass die neue version nicht
funktioniert nicht ist richtig
ok keine ahnung ich ich probiere das jetzt einfach aus wird wir testen wir
testen das jetzt einfach mehr als kaputt machen können was nicht aber in der
regel kann da eigentlich nichts kaputt gehen außer dass nicht funktioniert
schau mal auf manufacturer so wirklich ich habe auch die ich habe auch die
packung nicht mehr keine ahnung schau bei den gpr aus die eine hat zwei
relays ach ja
haben noch beide zwei relays sie müssten zwei relays haben einmal dafür
und einmal für die usb ich nehme einfach das hier jetzt fertig easy
gucken jetzt aus funktioniert zack konfigure template zack activate hick
insetzen safe easy prick da prickt sich nix
ostchamp so gucken ob er rebooted er ist wieder da zack da sind wir
moment aus da an erkennt man das ist blau aus an funktioniert ich kann euch
auch zeigen ich kann euch auch zeigen der der ein der andere toggle toggle usb
ich zeige euch auch jetzt dass es funktioniert wo ist die poggers lampe
hier poggers lamp
wo ist das wo ist das netzteil stecker
alter geht nicht so einfach ein stecker lampe
lampe ist noch aus und jetzt passt auf an beim kunst lampe aus aus also seht das
läuft ja die art das müssen wir gleich noch kalibrieren die anzeige ist
cac weight 290 volt china chinesen kram kannst du kannst du knicke das müssen
wir gleich noch kalibrieren haben die auch eine api das machen wir jetzt das
machen wir jetzt alles muss man das mal aufschreiben nicht vergessen wir machen
es mqtt wir machen calibration und home assistant integration aber alles
du kannst es über das web interface zoggen du kannst über eine web api
toggle oder kannst du mqtt toggle das ist viel besser also das motor kann fast
fast alles ansteuern so und für was das zweite schalter ist kann ich euch auch
zeigen der zweite schalter ist für usb die sache ist nun die ich habe jetzt
hier nix da was ich per usb kurz gucken was ich per usb anschließen kann also
der zweite schalter ist hierfür guckt er hat mach ich macht es mal wieder weg das
steht sonst wirklich nur im weg rum
guckt das ding an unten usb der zweite der zweite ist der zweite schalter ist
für usb ich überlege gerade was mache ich das mal bei den rest of the pie nicht
den brauche ich noch ach ich habe eine idee was ich dran mache hat doch hier
bestimmt ich habe doch noch irgendwo eine alte eine alte maus
hier guckt man so dreckig
ich habe hier kein gescheites usb gerät wo ich euch das jetzt mal zeigen
könnte über den exis point selbst exis point selbst an und ausschalten wird
ziemlich dumm da krieg ich nicht mal an
in die ladekabel ja ja aber das handy nimmt gerade auf ich habe ja kein gerät
nehme ich da mal per usb ich muss doch irgendein irgendein usb gerät ja haben
was das kann doch nicht sein aber denn hier
es
Es lag noch neben am Sofa, olle verstaubte Tastatur, aber ich glaube die hat RGB.
Olle verstaubte Tastatur, aber die können wir mal anschließen und wenn das funktioniert,
wenn ich jetzt den richtigen Stecker finde, den da, dann sollte es eigentlich angehen
per RGB.
Die Tastatur geht wohl erst an, wenn sie USB erkennt.
Ok das ist Paynes Champ, ihr müsst mir einfach glauben, dass du damit USB schaltest.
Ich habe das optimale Gerät gefunden, um euch zu zeigen, dass USB funktioniert.
Optimales Gerät, ich habe noch so ein USB Strommesser, guck USB funktioniert.
So, alter was willst du immer Windows, wenn ich das jetzt ausschalte, ist aus, wenn ich
es anschalte, geht es an, also ich glaube besser demonstrieren kann man es nicht, auch
mit 5 Volt, wie das sein sollte.
So und das heißt hiermit toggle ich die Steckdose, mit dem anderen kann ich USB ausschalten,
machen wir beides aus, jetzt USB auch aus.
So, so funktioniert es, ich glaube jetzt hat man es gesehen.
So und jetzt kommen wir mal dazu, was man cooles mit TAS Motor noch machen kann.
Was wir jetzt machen werden ist, weil gab es ja gerade die Frage, ob man das über API
steuern kann, das Motor kann man über alles möglich steuern, müsst ihr auch den USB Strom
verbrauchen, ja dafür ist es gedacht, also das kann ihr sagen, wieviel Volt auf dem USB
Anschluss sind, wieviel Ampere gerade drüber gehen und im Endeffekt kannst du dir dann
auch ungefähr ausrechnen, was es verbraucht.
So, also jetzt haben wir die Steckdose und jetzt kommt das Beste, das ganze müssen wir
jetzt in unsere Home Automation integrieren.
Das ist unsere Test Home Assistant Installation und es ist mittlerweile relativ simpel, Home
Assistant und TAS Motor miteinander zu verbinden, ich zeige euch das ganze mal, wie easy das
mittlerweile ist.
Was wir machen müssen ist erstmal, ja das 290, kalibrieren müssen wir ja auch noch,
habe ich ganz vergessen, ja ja, kalibrieren machen wir dann, wir verbinden es jetzt erstmal
mit Home Assistant, dass wir das schön verwenden können.
So, da muss wir in Configuration gehen, Configuration, Configuration und dann nach zu MQTT, da gibt
man jetzt ein die IP vom Home Assistant, Port 1338, das ist ja das, was wir eben gerade hier
auch in der Firewall freigeschaltet haben, dass es funktioniert, ja, also Forward zu
213, Port 1883, weil wir das hier brauchen, also, TAS Motor soll sich verbinden dahin,
so, User, ich habe keine Ahnung, was haben wir denn für einen User für MQTT vergeben,
Configure, ne, warte mal, wo ist das nochmal, Configuration, ach der Default User haben
wir, der Default User ist glaube ich Admin 123456, können wir mal gucken.
Wir gucken jetzt einfach, ob sich das verbinden kann, also, MQTT Verbindung, Passwort 123456,
User Admin glaube ich, ich würde normalerweise dafür und habe ich auch bei meinen Geräten
gemacht, ich würde einen extra User anlegen, ehrlich gesagt, aber gucken wir mal, ob das
sich verbinden kann, don't save, New Connection, Bam, jawoll, funktioniert.
Also, unser TAS Motor kann zumindest schon mit unserem MQTT reden und jetzt ist eigentlich
die Sache schon fast geritzt, jetzt geht man in die Configuration, sagt Add New Integration,
TAS Motor, das ist mittlerweile ziemlich easy im Vergleich zu früher, ja, man kann MQTT
natürlich auch über HTTPS, nicht über HTTPS, also verschlüsselt machen, aber meistens
ist es tatsächlich das ganz normale und verschlüsselt, ja, so, TAS Motor, we discover these, want
to set up, okay, das kenne ich noch nicht, yes, Submit, guck mal und schaut mal, dass
sie erkannt, Gosund, 112v3, TAS Motor, finished, so und jetzt habe ich 21 Entities von meiner
Steckdose hier drinne, unter anderem habe ich jetzt hier meine Heimautomatisierung drinne,
kann man das hier vielleicht ein bisschen, ja doof, also ich hab, wo ist es, ne, das
meint es der Heizchamp, das ist falsch, den Heizchamp wollen wir heute nicht, hier, ja,
wir haben Energieverbrauch, Datumzeug, man kann es an und ausschalten und sowas in der
Richtung, Disabled Entities, so, jetzt sollten wir das erstmal ordentlich benennen, weil
die haben Autodiscovery drinne, mittlerweile ist Home Assistant, MQTT, Autodiscovery startmess
dabei, so, wir sollten die Dinge jetzt erstmal ordentlich benennen, dass wir wissen was
was ist, so, weil später hast du 5 Steckdosen und alle heißen TAS Motor, deswegen sagen
wir jetzt mal Name, das da ist, gehen wir mal, machen wir mal ein Beispiel, keine Ahnung,
was würden wir jetzt verwenden für Wohnzimmer, das war das Schwachsinn, Wohnzimmer, TV, so,
und das hier ist USB, also Wohnzimmer, TV, USB, also ich würde die Dinger irgendwie
sinnvoll verwenden, benutzen, dass ich die später wieder finde, ja, ich weiß man kann
seine Steckdose vergeben, aber ich mag das hier eher, so, jetzt können wir mal gucken,
ob das richtig gemapt ist, ich mach mal USB an, und USB geht an, ich mach USB aus, und
USB geht aus, ist richtig gemapt, ihr sehts ja hier, guckt, USB an, und USB aus, funktioniert,
richtig gemapt, Stromverbraucher ist noch ziemlich pepega, funktioniert auch nicht,
aber nachdem wir das ganze jetzt in unserem Home Assistant drin haben, können wir jetzt
einfach sagen, ich schieb das mal kurz hier unten hin, und jetzt einfach sagen, ok, ich
will das mal in mein Dashboard integrieren, so hier haben wir die Heizung, da ist es vielleicht
nicht so sinnvoll, das heißt wir machen jetzt mal ein neues Tab, und zwar ein neues Tab
fürs Wohnzimmer, Icon, MDI, was ist ein schönes Icon für Wohnzimmer, TV vielleicht, weiß
ich nicht, ob das gültig ist, Safe, Icon, MDI, Icons, Couch, Couch ist gut, wir gucken
mal was es für Icons gibt, Couch, Alter, diese Seite ist so krass langsam, Couch, ja hier,
das ist doch gut für Wohnzimmer, Sofa, Sofa heißt es, das ist doch gut, Sofa, da ist
es, zack, ist unser Sofa, also wir haben jetzt Tabs für alles was wir brauchen, wir haben
unseren Keller, den machen wir mal weg, so wir haben das Home Tab, das benennen wir auch
mal um, bin ich doof, das heißt MDI, Home, so, jetzt haben wir Tabs, Michael, 50 Billionen,
du bist auch am Start, endlich, guck mal, wir haben gerade Tasmota geflasht, und weißt
du, da habe ich gleich an dich gedacht, weißt du wie die aktuelle Tasmota Version heißt,
guck mal, schon gedacht, wo ist er denn, so, jetzt haben wir unser, jetzt haben wir unser
Dashboard eingestellt, das hier ist Techt, also wir haben Dashboard für Home, Dashboard
fürs Wohnzimmer, Dashboard für den Keller mit der Heizung drin, hast du das neue Video
vom Auer gesehen, ja, teilweise zumindest, teilweise, können wir uns am Sonntag komplett
angucken, da kann ich ein bisschen Sellout für mein Hetzer Cloud Code machen, so und
hier bilden wir jetzt die Steckdose ein, also, so, wir brauchen ein Button, Wohnzimmer TV,
das schlägt da sogar schon vor, nicht weil das Wohnzimmer ist, sondern weil das das
einzige ist, was wir wahrscheinlich haben, so, ShowState können wir noch dran machen,
on, off, ShowIcon, Icon ist sinnvoll, ShowName, ja, ist vielleicht nicht verkehrt, so, und
jetzt haben wir einen Knopf, wo wir unsere Steckdose ein und ausmachen können in unserem
Dashboard, das Dashboard lässt sich bedienen, Tablet, Smartphone, Desktop, überall, Integration,
total einfach, was ich jetzt noch empfehlen würde ist folgendes, weil man wahrscheinlich
im Wohnzimmer ein bisschen mehr als eine Steckdose hat, würde ich das anders machen und das
ist auch ein bisschen fett, ich würde hier eine, ein Grid noch machen, ein Grid mit drei
Columns und da würde ich das reinstecken, das ist sinnvoller, ja, dann machen wir Wohnzimmer
USB und Wohnzimmer, jetzt ist übrigens auch wichtig, dass die halt richtig benannt sind,
sonst würde man die hier nicht mehr gescheit finden, Wohnzimmer, so, der Name ist ein bisschen
groß, also überschreiben wir den Namen mal und sagen, einfach mal ShowName ausnehmen
und sagen wir, EV-USB, oh nee, umgedreht, EV und das hier ist VUSB, so, und die schmeißen
wir weg und schon haben wir in unserem Wohnzimmer zwei Knöpfe, wo wir Geräte mit an- und ausschalten
können, wir konnten unseren Fernseher an- und ausschalten, das schaltet jetzt hier an-
und aus, die Steckdose oder wir können USB-Geräte an- und ausschalten, das schaltet, wie man
sieht, hier an- und aus, guckt, an, aus, an, geht, so und da muss man echt sagen, die Integration
ist ziemlich easy gewesen, oder, das jetzt in Home Assistant zu integrieren, um nicht
zu sagen, was im Netto-Zentrallager, das Serverraum ist voll mit RGB, warum habt ihr RGB im Serverraum,
also das bunte LEDs vorne an den Servern sind ja aber RGB, ja Chainlord, deswegen musst
du ihnen das ja auch machen, so, jetzt können wir hier unseren Fernseher an- und ausschalten
und ihr seht auch, die Latency ist durchaus in Ordnung hier, guckt, aus, an, aus, an,
also die Latency ist vollkommen ok, so und in Wirklichkeit hätte man jetzt natürlich
noch mehr Einträge, ja man könnte hier beispielsweise sein Android-TV als Player reinmachen, oder
was auch immer noch alles, in dem Fall haben wir jetzt halt nur zwei Steckdosen drinne,
so und jetzt wollen wir ja kalibrieren, hatten wir noch gesagt, weil das ganze ein wenig
unrealistisch ist, 290 Volt, das stimmt was nicht, das blöde ist, warum ich das jetzt
nur, ja sagen wir mal, sehr behelfsmäßig kalibrieren kann ist, ich hab nichts da, wovon
ich weiß, was das braucht, ich kann, ich kann jetzt, ich kann jetzt das hier anpassen, dass
das nicht stimmt, ich kann das jetzt, ich kann das jetzt anpassen auf 230 Volt und gucken,
also, dass er das anders rechnet, aber ich hab keine Klübchen da und ich hab auch keine
gescheite Fassung da, um das anzuschließen, ich hab's letztes Mal mit einem Heizlüfter
gemacht, da geht das auch, ging das auch ganz gut, aber ich hab jetzt nichts gescheites
da, du machst immer mit einem 5 Watt Netzteil vom Handy, ja gut, aber dann weißt du ja nicht,
was, ob das wirklich 5, glaub sau geil, ne ich hab da glaub ich nichts gescheites, aber
wir können zumindest mal gucken, wie man das kalibrieren würde, weil das ist in Tasmota
ein bisschen, sag mal ein bisschen um die Ecke, Tasmota Calibration, Gosund, da steht
das wahrscheinlich auch irgendwo drin oder, Gosund, Power Monitoring Calibration, genau,
so was muss man machen, Rate Multimeter, Alter, ich sag mal gut, ich hab ein schiller Chinesen
Multimeter, so, Power Set, Very Far Power Reading, ja das stimmt nicht, Voltage Set
will ich machen, Voltage Set, da können wir jetzt zum Beispiel sagen, hey, da gehen wir
in die Konsole, sagen Voltage Set 230, und wenn wir Glück haben, sieht das jetzt schon
ein bisschen besser aus, so und jetzt könnten wir testen, ob der Verbrauch halbwegs stimmt,
ich hab aber nichts, ums damit zu testen, Moin, it's Fifa Pro, ich hab leider nichts
gescheites, ums zu testen, also ich muss mal gucken, ob ich das iPad zum Beispiel mal laden
kann oder so, wir probieren das mal aus, wir laden mal das, wir laden mal das iPad, guck
mal, da hab ich doch was da, wir können sogar halbwegs genau gucken, ob das, ob das,
ne, können wir nicht, kommen wir hier rein, iPad, iPad dran, so und nun, achso, es ist
eingeschaltet, ok, wir verbrauchen angeblich 17 Watt, das erscheint mir ein bisschen viel,
aber ich kann das nicht in den USB Messer stecken, weil das so ne dumme, so ein dummes,
hier, Ding ist, USB-C, und ich glaub, der hat kein, hat der USB-C, ah, der hat USB-C, easy,
da können wir tatsächlich gucken, ob das stimmt, wirklich, können wir doch gucken,
ob das stimmt, also der meint, äh, der meint gar nichts, ah, das ist Input, das ist, das
ist ja dumm, das ist nur Input, das bringt mir ja gar nichts, es gibt nur den als Output,
ah, Paintschamp, alter, da brauch ich, ich brauch, ich brauch nen, ich brauch nen, nen
Lightning-Kabel, hab ich nicht noch nen Lightning-Kabel mit normalen USB dran, muss ich doch hier
irgendwo haben, man, was ist denn das hier zum Beispiel, hahaha, Leute, ich hab nen
Lightning-Kabel gefunden, aber guckt mal, richtiger Anschluss, alles klar, aber jetzt,
Achtung, Achtung, hahaha, es war mal ein Lightning-Kabel, ich hab wahrscheinlich, ähm, Kabel gebraucht,
hahaha, ähm, ok, ich hab doch bestimmt noch mehr, Lightning-Kabel aus, Lightning, ich
hab doch bestimmt irgendwo noch nen Lightning-Kabel, glaub ich hab im Schlafzimmer noch eins,
Zack, ich geh mal schnell in den Schlafzimmer, ich glaub ich hab im Schlafzimmer eins, zum
Aufladen, oder hab ich hier vielleicht, umschreibt sich noch eins, ich bin gleich wieder da, ich
hab ne, ich hab eine, ja, ich hab ne, ich hab ne, ich hab ne, ja, ich hab ne, ich hab
Ok.
Die
die
meine
wir haben 5 volt 1,4 ampere also 7 watt ungefähr wenn das stimmt erkennt man das
überhaupt bei euch gescheit also halbwegs oder so wirklich so wirklich gut nicht 7 watt haben
angeblich meine steckdose a fuck guck mal der misst usb nicht rip alda rip jetzt bräuchte ich
ein usb nennt 230 auf usb um das dann da einzustecken so was habe ich jetzt nicht mehr da
so normal ich meine ich könnte die steckdose da oben reinstecken steckdose in steckdose
aber so eine so eine
habe ich bestimmt leute ich brauche nur usb netz teil habe ich doch habe ich doch bestimmt
irgendwo hier das problem ist ich habe hier so viel zeug rumliegen ich habe garantiert
ein usb netz teil steckdosen selbst ich weiß wo ich ein usb netz teil habe
ali express regelt ali express regelt guck mal hier best best hersteller best best
hersteller shit tech das ist irgendwie ein zwanziger pack die habe ich mal gekauft auch
in china shit tech der name alleins schon man sagt alles ok das raus shit tech rein
zack gut ah ne zack stimmt nicht so rum lull was ein teil was ein turm alter was ein turm
ah jetzt sind wir bei jetzt sind wir bei 10 watt er kennt die glaube ich ist auch ganz
gut ok 10 watt was haben wir hier 14 also es ist ein bisschen oft würde ich sagen ne
so er ist da mein 0,077 und in wirklichkeit sind es 2 amt ja gut das ist spannungswandlung
und so das kann man jetzt das kann man hier nicht nicht wirklich zählen das das geht
ja das das geht ja quasi 230 volt auf auf 5 volt das das das passt nicht also das hier
das kann schon sein dass es ein bisschen mehr braucht ich mein das ist ja nur wirklich
nicht nix wirklich soll ich aussage kräftig ist hier weiß ich weiß ich da was ich da
gerade sehe ja wir können es wir können es vielleicht ein bisschen anpassen noch und
noch ein bisschen runter also wir können jetzt irgendwie sagen power calibration power set
ok welfare power reading ok power set sagen wir mal power set 12 ok das kommt jetzt ungefähr
hin easy so wir könnten das jetzt wir könnten das jetzt einfach testen ich könnte ins bad
und meinen heizlüfter anschließen soll ich machen der müsste ungefähr 1000 watt brauchen
wenn er an ist aber scheiß drauf oder ja mach was ausprobieren ich ich mach den heizlüfter
ok
So, ich hoffe, dieser Billig-Access-Polizei hat euch gefallen und ich hoffe, dass ihr
dieser Billig-Access-Point reicht bis ins Bad.
Ich habe jetzt wieder angeschlossen.
Haha, funktioniert.
Funktioniert?
Okay.
On.
Sooo...
Also ich meine, hey, es ist fucking ungenau, aber sooo ungenau ist es jetzt auch nicht.
Es kommt schon ungefähr hin.
Das kommt schon ungefähr hin.
Oh, RIP.
So.
Äh, was hab ich jetzt verkehrt gemacht?
Was hab ich jetzt, das macht man wahrscheinlich nicht so, oder?
Nein, nein, ich hab keine Lampe.
Ich hab keine Lampe, dass wir das ordentlich machen könnten.
Gut, scheiß drauf.
Dann sieht man mal wieder, man muss das richtig machen, aber ich kann's grad nicht ordentlich
machen.
Ich hab die passende Hardware dafür nicht.
Ich hab ein Multimeter, aber ich kann jetzt da bestimmt nicht ins Bad mit und halt das
da dran.
So.
Wunderbar.
Das ist ja auch nur eine Kleinigkeit, schauen wir mal aus.
Also, Flaschen hat funktioniert, einbittenden Home Assistant hat funktioniert, alles gut,
wunderbar, tut.
Guck, jetzt kann ich meinen Fernseher, also meinen Heizlüfter, da drüber ausschalten.
Und das Beste ist, dadurch, dass ich das jetzt so ein bisschen ungefähr in die Richtung
kalibriert habe.
Jetzt haben wir eine Steckdose von 400, die anderen wäre ich jetzt, jetzt weiß man ja,
wie's funktioniert.
Aber was auch noch ganz cool ist, dadurch, dass ich jetzt die ganzen Infos habe von dem
Gerät, kann ich zum Beispiel jetzt hier auch sagen, hey, wenn mich mein Stromverbrauch
interessiert, da gibt's jetzt was Neues, also entweder kann ich sowas hier machen, wenn
ich das sehen will, das Motor, Current, sonst was und dann werdet ihr sehen, wenn ich das
jetzt speichere und ich mach den hier an, dann geht das gleich rauf, sollte zumindest.
Oder auch nicht, ach, das ist schon 3 Minutes ago, aber 0,84 Ampere kann ja schlecht sein.
Was sagt das Motor selbst, das Motor sagt 4, scheint sich nicht so schnell zu updaten.
Dann, dann nicht, das muss man sich ein bisschen genauer angucken, zumindest, kommen wir mal
gucken, was es noch für Sachen gibt, die man einstellen kann, wir machen noch mal an,
ich glaube, der updatet sich wirklich einfach nicht so schnell, das stimmt, aber der Rest
updatet sich irgendwie nicht so, das ist unsere Test-Home Assistant Installation, kannst
du einstellen, wie schnell er sich updatet, alle 5 Minuten, nee, nee, F5 bringt nix, alle
5 Minuten, das ist ja nix, weißt du die Option dafür, zumindest wir können mal gucken, was
wir sonst noch, was wir sonst noch so einstellen können, Device Info, mehr gibt's anscheinend
gar nicht, mehr gibt's anscheinend gar nicht, Integration, PassMotor Firmware Version,
juckt mich nicht, MQTT Count, Last Restart Time, das Motor IP finde ich immer sinnvoll,
die zu enablen, dass man nachgucken kann, was für ein IP das Ding hat, ok, ich schaue
mal, das Motor Option Update MQTT Energy, was Teleperiod, Teleperiod, see current value
and false publish state and sensor message, ah die fault, ok, das ist tatsächlich, Teleperiod,
also wir machen jetzt einfach mal Teleperiod 5, das sind halt alle 5 Sekunden, so, hä,
she baited, ich sag 5, das ist einfach 10, wahrscheinlich ist 10 das kleinste, maximal
10, achja hier 10, also alle 10 Sekunden, alle 10 Sekunden update jetzt, gut, das bedeutet
jetzt ja auch, wenn ich jetzt, wenn ich jetzt einschalte, den Heizlüfter, was man hier
schon sieht, dass das ziemlich rauf geht, ah, ah, ah, so, das ganze kann ich jetzt
schön in meinen Dashboard verbinden, so, das Motor hat ein neues Feature, hat irgendwie
Energy Consumption Crit, hab ich noch nie verwendet, ich mach den Heizlüfter erstmal
wieder aus, aber könnten wir jetzt eigentlich uns mal kurz anklicken, ich hab keine Ahnung,
was das ist, configure amount Energy Consume Crit, ach ne, das ist irgendwie für Solaranlage
und sowas, next, Solar Panels, lul, weh, alter, das ist für Solar Panels, next, next, Battery
System, next, Gas Consumption, next, Individual Devices, Sieh mal, Add Devices, Gas Motor,
total Energy, save, ja super, das bringt mir ja gar nichts, das ist, das ist was für Leute
mit Solaranlagen und sowas, wo ich übrigens auch überlegen bin, ob ich mir nicht eine
Solaranlage jetzt mal endlich aufs Dach mache, ich wollte mir demnächst einen von den Stadtwerken
bestellen, der mich mal berät, ich weiß nicht, wie gut die das können, aber das muss man
echt sagen, das ist schon nice, easy Integration, Home Assistant, Knopf gedrückt, Lüfter im
Fahrrad geht an und man sieht sogar den Stromverbrauch, wobei das jetzt das falsche ist, um den Stromverbrauch
anzuzeigen, wir brauchen die aktuelle Leistung, das denn, das ist das Motor Power, Energy Power,
das brauchen wir und jetzt Bam und jetzt sollte der gleich irgendwas 950 Watt oder so anzeigen
oder auch nicht, ah jetzt, das ist doch richtig nice oder, das ist doch richtig Pock, so jetzt
kann man vielleicht ein bisschen was sinnvolles hier einstellen, wobei was wollen wir da großartig
einstellen, Maximum 1000, keine Ahnung, ist reichlich sinnlos jetzt überhaupt sich das
anzeigen zu lassen, aber es ist cool, dass es so einfach funktioniert, also das muss
man den Jungs bei Home Assistant wirklich mal lassen, die Standardsachen fürs Dashboard
sind optisch und bedienungsmäßig wirklich gut gemacht, so, jetzt haben wir unsere Huge
das Motor Steckdose eingebunden, ey mach doch schon was her, die Info brauche ich jetzt
nicht wirklich, ehrlich gesagt ist die Info relativ überflüssig, dass mein Heizluft
der 922 Watt gerade braucht, aber why not, wieviel die Steckdose ab kann, ist eine gute
Frage, ich weiß nicht, ob die 10 oder 16 Ampere rated ist, aber was die China-Chinesen
so raten, weiß ich nicht, gucken wir mal, be smart 24, wenn die flashbar ist geht der
Preis sogar halb fix in Ordnung, Specs, ich hab keine Ahnung, das steht wieder nicht
da, seht ihr irgendwas, 16, ach hier, ja dann müssten 16 sein, oder, ist das 230 mal
16, was ist 230 mal 16, okay das passt, ja 16, also sagen die China-Chinesen, sagen
16 Ampere, ob das dann wirklich so ist, also ich würde da jetzt nicht unbedingt noch eine
Steckdosenleiste mit 3 Heizlüfter dran hängen, gut wunderbar, ja so funktioniert das, so
funktioniert das, so macht man das, China Steckdosen, China-Chinesen Steckdosen flashen,
ich werde mir jetzt sparen die anderen 3, hast du ein Affiliate-Link für AliExpress?
Nein, habe ich nicht, ich werde mir jetzt sparen die anderen 3 auch zu flashen, weil
die Katze geht mir schon auf den Keks, die steht schon vor der Tür und kratzt da dran
rum, glaube ich muss jetzt Schluss machen und mich um meine Katze kümmern, aber ich hoffe
es hat euch trotzdem gefallen, war wieder Poggers Stream und wir haben eigentlich alles
gemacht was wir machen wollten, calibriert MQTT, Home Assistant, Integration, Small Cute
Access Point, perfekt, also Leute, wo kann man die Gosund kaufen, kann man so nicht sagen,
ich frage jetzt, ob man die Version noch kaufen kann, die geflashed wird, Leute, irgendeine
Idee, wen ich hosten kann, wer macht dann, sag mal, YouTube, Battlefield, was gibt's
denn da gerade, nicht YouTube, Twitch, was haben wir da für Battlefield Streams, Moment,
Battlefield 2, 42, nein, Null, äh, wie gibt's bei Battlefield 3, Leute, ach ja, Battlefield
3, Amorant, Just Dance, hat äußerst viel mit Battlefield 3 zu tun, muss ich sagen,
kaum jemand, Story, 0W, tja, egal, Leute, ich geh jetzt auf, macht's gut, bis denn, bis
zum nächsten Mal, nächsten Stream, gucken wir mal, wann das nächste Video kommt, das
nächste Video ist eigentlich geplant, das Video mit der Endpunkt, aber vielleicht mach
ich vorher noch einen Stellenanzeigen im Video, je nachdem, was ich früher oder besser hinkriege,
also wir sehen uns, Leute, bis denn, ich hoffe, euch hat's gefallen, see you, macht's gut.